by the way you're you're kind of
accident prone aren't you yeah well how
do you know that well because you got in
a horrible car crash does that make me
accident was it your fault no okay then
you're right the accident
I was like I would never know hey I got
in a car it wasn't my fault how does
that mean the accident well you were you
were there your phone to get an accident
I was 14 in the back seat but you know
what
that makes me accident Pro no like
tripping and fall like sure oh you do
that yeah but I was in horrific car
accident when I was 14. yeah because Rob
told me that it was pretty traumatic
yeah Rob told you about my car accident
or you asked I asked oh okay I was like
that's really random oh yeah um yeah
yeah I said you know is there you know
anything [__] like really bad that
happened in her life we can talk about I
remember everything up until the point
that uh the accident happened so I black
out I have no memory of the actual
accident
um helicopter to the hospital jaws of
life like all the good you almost died
yeah I think so I think like I lost you
know the signs for a few minutes
um you went Code Blue I don't know maybe
yeah I don't know Flatline for a second
maybe or two I I have the police report
you're saying maybe on all these things
again if I got in a horrible car
accident and I was pronounced dead I
would remember these things I wasn't
pronounced dead I mean I feel like that
would have been a big you know
it's a big
I'm sorry for laughing dude are you
kidding I have
I have car accidents are [__]
hilarious yeah I was in a car accident
it was crazy but how bad no no I didn't
nothing really happened
um we were just lucky we were like yeah
we were going to Depeche Mode concert
nice on the way back home 1991 violator
tour whoever wanted
was here in my arms and we're going and
Rick Camacho's tires were bald and it's
raining and he's just going around like
you know cars are coming this way we're
going
and it just hydroplane kept going into
their Lane and I saw this truck coming
oh no and I go oh my God I grabbed my
pillow and I went behind Jacobs Jacob
was in the passenger seat and I just I
remember forever here I was like
oh oh God
oh and all of a sudden it was just
silence oh that's and I looked over and
Jacob had like blood on his head no and
Rick was like oh my God oh my God and
the car was smashed right up to their
legs like right another half of three
inches and their legs would have been
gone oh my God and it was it was true
see remember I remember that because
nothing I I remember exactly what
happened because I was I didn't pass out
but you lost Consciousness were
helicoptered out were you losing a lot
of blood I don't know maybe internal
ones it was like I think part of my head
was like kind of scalped a little bit
like I have a scar but it's weird it
stops like right here at my hairline so
you can't see it but it was like yeah
like you know black eye scalped up here
uh I think I was in a coma for like a
little tiny bit were you with your
parents no no no no no no no no no no no
I was with um my friends my friend who
was driving who was 16 and we were
dating these guys that were older they
were not good guys and um partying on
the beach you know Strawberry Hill if
you're familiar oh yeah yeah Boons oh
yeah oh yeah come on now I'm gonna have
a little Bartles and James yeah you know
of course you don't know [__]
two young these youngins yeah so like we
were all kind of partying it was in
Oxnard and we were driving in the and
the dude in the passenger seat that was
my friend's whatever was turned around
on his knees tickling the guy I was with
who was like laying on me in the back
seat
and at one point he just got his hand
and he yanked the steering wheel the guy
in the passenger seat we're on PCH going
you know pretty fast and he just yanked
the wheel and we went over into oncoming
traffic and we were in a little Ford
Probe which is I don't know if they make
them anymore they're really small and we
hit like a big truck
uh maybe it was even like did anyone die
Chuck no if one guy is paralyzed
um god the guy with me is mentally not
well I don't think and uh I think he's
in jail for murder maybe I shouldn't say
that I don't know
um yeah but anyway it was very gnarly oh
my God could I black out was your friend
okay yeah like her foot was kind of like
hanging off or something but she was
okay and this is really uplifting story
yeah the last image I have is his hand
on the steering wheel and then that's
all I remember why what do you've done
that
they were on drugs
oh maybe speed I forgot definitely not
Strawberry Hill definitely not yeah no
definitely not just that so you probably
had to did you go through therapy with
that stuff about Rehabilitation or well
no like we were in the hospital and like
I said like it was a head injury so I
don't I always wonder though if at some
point is it just gonna come back to me
like and that's a little terrifying like
is that just gonna like sometime just
pop up I wonder if the EMDR I guarantee
it would why then I don't want to do it
well no if you if you you choose the
incident you choose the trauma oh okay
you don't need to revisit that term no
no it sounds like you do not I'm good
with it you don't need to go backwards
like a horror movie I want to go back to
this time where I almost died does it
affect you no why do you want to go back
there right I just do you know it's kind
of [__] you don't want to do it no I
don't want to do that